[Musique]
post 9 et 12 n'ont que le genou droit
marie christine lagarde génois de rachat
de wind land and watch au web proposés
comme pour toutes les victoires pour
donald trump
aujourd'hui madame monsieur bonsoir
hills and marriage sont bienvenues cette
émission spéciale sur les conclusions du
rapport muller et bientôt ils
attendaient cette nouvelle depuis 22
mois combien de fois l'avez vous entendu
dire nos colonnes lui qui a toujours
aussi répété que c'était une chasse aux
sorcières
le procureur général william moore a
rendu publique une lettre de quatre
pages qui résume les conclusions du
rapport muller deux grandes conclusions
la première le procureur spécial muller
n'a pas trouvé de preuves de
conspiration des collusions avec il faut
bien le noter le gouvernement russe pour
son ingérence dans l'élection
présidentielle de 2016 on va la
décortiquer cette première conclusion au
cours de cette émission
deuxième conclusion celle là beaucoup
plus nuancée concerne le comportement du
président from at il oui ou non fait
entrave à la justice notamment en
congédiant le directeur du fbi et james
cromitie il ne peut pas établir hors de
tout doute raisonnable que les c'est ce
critère qu'il a fait entrave à la
justice mais ne peut l'exonérer non plus
nous allons en discuter avec vos invités
sur le plateau et aux états unis d'abord
à mes côtés raphaël jacob chercheur
associé à la roule à la chaire raoul
dandurand bonsoir bonsoir charles ribe
d'avis le président l'observatoire et
fondateur de la chaire bonsoir charles
soirée
mais d'abord allons rejoindre celui qui
au coeur de l'action que sans le trahir
washington l'eau soit christian pas de
conclusion pas de preuves suffisantes
d'entravé à la justice il aura fallu
quand même à une batterie d'avocats au
moins 19 40 agents du fbi
1 2800 citation 500 t de 5 500 témoins
25 millions de drams quand même une
trentaine d'accusations en périphérie à
washington on parle de 665 jourde
enquêtes qui ont été éprouvants pour le
président hu y ait des conclusions qui
peuvent paraître décevante certainement
pour pour les démocrates
mais en même temps il ne fallait pas
s'attendre à quelque chose de
spectaculaire de la part de monsieur
morue parce que vous savez tout ce qu'il
a fait tout le travail qu'il a réalisé
avec avec son équipe les résultats
étaient rendus publics et au fur et à
mesure alors on se demandait bien en fin
de course ce qu'il allait rester de
cette enquête et on le voit bien
ça se résume en quatre petites pages
avec deux conclusions assez solides à
ces marteaux c'est à dire que tout
d'abord oui il ya eu interférence des
russes
les russes se sont ingérés en piratant
des comptes informatique en semant de
fausses informations sur les réseaux
sociaux mais on a été incapable de
démontrer que l'entourage la famille les
proches de monsieur jobs et monsieur
jobs lui-même avait aidé ces mêmes
russes à le favoriser
durant la campagne présidentielle de
2016 deuxième conclusion très importante
et vous avez raison de le mentionner en
introduction peut-être un peu plus
nuancé
c'est à dire que monsieur bart dans son
résumé mentionne que monsieur maurer l'a
pas été en mesure même s'ils ne va ni
d'un côté ni de l'autre monsieur
beaulieu mentionne entre autres
c'est pas parce que on ne prétend qui
est qu on prétend que monsieur thiam n'a
pas commis de crime qu'on l'exonère
complètement ce sera au procureur
général de décider s'il ya eu entrave à
la justice
et là on parle bien sûr de du
congédiement entre autres de james comme
et l'ex-directeur du du fbi et monsieur
barre répond à cette question aussi dans
le rapport en disant je ne pense pas
avec tout ce que j'ai vu dans le rapport
moller qui lie à place à des accusations
pour entrave à la justice
alors c'est un peu le résumé de ce
rapport et je pense que on est en mesure
oui messieurs chara c'est ça son dernier
après avoir quitté son golf the weekend
washington était ravi de parler à la
presse on écoute
voilà après une longue enquête après
très longue enquête
après plusieurs personnes qui ont été
heurté et blessé après ne pas avoir
examiné l'autre côté de la médaille ou
plusieurs choses sont arrivées de
l'autre côté aussi beaucoup de mauvaises
choses pour notre nation
ça vient d'être annoncée il y a eu
aucune collusion avec la russie c'est ce
sont des accusations ridicules il n'y
avait pas de collusion avec la russie
pas d'obstruction rien du tout et ça a
été une exonération complète et totale
c'est dommage ce qu'on a pu subir comme
nation honnêtement c'est dommage que
votre président ait eu à vivre tout ça
avant même d'être élu
ça a commencé et ça a commencé
illégalement et j'espère que quelqu'un
va regarder de l'autre côté ça a été une
attaque illégale qui n'a pas réussi et
j'espère que quelqu'un va regarder
l'autre côté parce que c'est une
exonération totale pas de collusion pas
d'obstruction merci merci beaucoup
alors c'est un président mal de contre
attaque christian qui a quitté miami
vers washington d'ailleurs on devrait
probablement lors des images de son
arrivée tout à l'heure à washington cela
dit il ya quand même quelque chose ce
sont des images en direct
alors ça c'est air force one que ça
presse sans doute a intérêt à washington
alors christian au moins ce qui est
clair malgré les nombreuses affirmations
par les agents du renseignement aux
états unis avaient bel et bien de
l'ingérence russe
tout ce que le rapport dit c'est qui on
peut pas prouver que le président
lui-même ni ses officiers de campagne
sont liés au rapt commis un crime en
lien avec le gouvernement
non et cette enquête peu importe ce
qu'en pense et ce qu'en dit dans notre
chambre elle avait une légitimité vous
savez on a commencé à observer beaucoup
de gens effectivement qu'avait rencontré
des russes dans l'entourage de monsieur
jobs
rappelez vous de cette fameuse rencontre
du mois de juin 2016
ça a soulevé toutes sortes de questions
alors c'était c'était légitime de
demander une enquête en profondeur
après tous ces mois dans quête
maintenant est ce que les démocrates
pourront continuer à taper sur ce clou
déjà on voit que madame pirlo si
monsieur schummer les leaders démocrates
au congrès 10 à ce que l'on voit ce soir
ce que l'on lit
c'est la version de williams bar
procureur général des etats-unis qui a
été nommé par d'un autre homme
nous on veut voir tout le rapport on
veut voir la substance on veut être en
mesure de tirer nos propres conclusions
et attendez vous à ce que monsieur morin
et est ce que monsieur bart ne sera
seront appelés comme témoins dans
différentes commissions au congrès pour
aller vraiment au fond des choses mais
vous savez le public américain commence
à en avoir assez absent d'une lassitude
il ya une lassitude qui s'installe et
politiquement ça va devenir très
dangereux pour les démocrates de
toujours jouer cette carte contre
monsieur jobs oui en effet la nomination
du procureur général avait soulevé déjà
la contreverse on le soupçonne d'être en
conflit d'intérêts
du côté démocrate notamment sur cette
question d' entrave à la justice parce
que il y croyait pas lui dès le départ
monsieur bara cette possibilité d'
entrave à la justice
et c'est là que la deuxième conclusion
doit être décortiquées comme il faut
aller très nuancée ouais effectivement
monsieur bart qui s'était montré dans
différents écrits très en faveur des
pouvoirs présidentiels et
avait à maintes reprises pris position
un peu contre monsieur marc le même
s'ils sont des amis mais contre ce
rapport comme cette chasse aux sorcières
alors monsieur tian parole beau jeu et
les républicains sont déjà en mode
attaque anne-marie et vous savez ils se
préparent pour 20 etc il faut pas je
pense qu'il faut reconnaître que ce soir
c'est une importante victoire pour le
président entre hommes qui pourra
toujours dire aux électeurs américains
voyez vous je vous l'avais dit je vous
avais prévenu nous avons fait l'objet
d'une grande partie de pêche d'une
chasse aux sorcières et je n'ai rien
fait de mal mon équipe n'a rien fait de
mal et cette enquête a été écouté très
cher aux contribuables américains et l'a
servi aucun intérêt mais déjà voulu
mentionner les démocrates vont
entreprendre cette partie de bras de fer
qui pourrait se rendre très loin même
devant les tribunaux américains on n'a
pas terminé puisque un équilibre fragile
pour eux en ce début de campagne
électorale pour se positionner aux
élections de 2001 parce qu'un homme
monsieur tron pour être tenté de
transformer cette victoire d'aujourd'hui
presque une victoire électorale pour
2020 ben a d'ailleurs créé rhialco louer
une de ses conseillères a dit monsieur
de chambre a gagné pour une deuxième
fois l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui
alors voilà comment est ce qu'on le
considère mais les démocrates vous savez
il y aura toujours ces enquêtes qui
continue dans le district sud de new
york
il y en a washington également ça ne
veut pas dire que ce n'est que les
problèmes de monsieur deux chambres se
termine ce soir en mairie
mais chose certaine sur toute l'histoire
de la russie la collusion
ce sera difficile et politiquement
dangereux pour les démocrates de
continuer à jouer cette carte est tapé
sur l'administration de choc
écoutez ça ne peut pas être plus clair
noir sur blanc même si elle en est après
dation de monsieur bart on doit le
croire ce soir on a peut-être la version
complète du rapport un jour pour que
tout le monde puisse se faire une tête
là dessus mais c'est très clair monsieur
marc eux n'a pas trouvé de preuves
suffisantes pour démontrer que son
entourage dit lui-même ont aidé les
russes en même temps il treize russes
qui sont inculpés inculpé flynn qui est
en prison qui est inculpé pour avoir
menti sur le fait qu'ils avaient
rencontré l'ambassadeur russe qui cela
qu'à l'époque il beaucoup de russes car
même qui tourne autour
mais le président est blanchi c'est ce
qu'il faut conclure et c'est ça qui est
important et je pense que c'est cette le
public américain va comprendre ça c'est
intéressant de voir les sondages
d'opinion au cours des prochains jours
mais vous restez avec nous au cours de
cette émission spéciale merci à
christian se joignent donc chanter david
et raphaël jacob
charles-philippe vous aussi ans tous les
deux ces deux ans vous qu'on parle de ça
alors là c'est le jour important pour
vous êtes devant une conclusion
alors quelle lecture faites-vous
trépidante les deux d'abord une première
réponse
satisfait de la réponse que je veux dire
c'est certainement la meilleure nouvelle
est du sic en a pas eu beaucoup dans
notre homme dans ce dossier là depuis
que toute cette histoire là commun c'est
là effectivement ce soir on annonce
qu'il n'ya pas en principe de coups
fumants de smoking en langue anglaise
dans l'implication du président pour
l'essayer effectivement de profiter de
l'aide de la russie pour gagner ces
élections contre hillary clinton disons
les choses comme elles sont
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui à
mon avis qui politiquement est l'une des
meilleure nouvelle que dans nos trente
pouvait recevoir
c'est quelque chose qui va l'aider en
termes d'image et de réputation bien
évident qu'il va rebondir avec ça et que
ça va l'aider
maintenant je me méfie de tout jour des
sommaires qu'on peut avoir de ceux de
ses rapports parce qu'il est volumineux
et que quatre pages ne peut certainement
pas rendre justice à toutes les nuances
et les détails certainement qu'on va n'y
trouvais ça c'est mon expérience de ce
genre de rapports depuis au moins une
trentaine d'années alors attendons mais
y est clair alors est elle oui c'est une
belle beau début pour dans notre robot -
pour le premier chef d'accusation phare
du deuxième epr pour le premier match
une enquête le deuxième motif d' enquête
entrave à la justice monsieur tron dit
écrit l'histoire là dessus aussi
j'ai plus nuancé c'est beaucoup plus
nuancé sur le deuxième point parce que
contrairement à ce que le président est
allé dire on l'entendît a pas de
quelques minutes on ne parle pas d'une
exonération totale du moins dans le
sommaire et je crois pas prendre la
balle au rebond parce que monsieur david
ont utilisé deux mots qui sont clés en
principe en principe c'est une victoire
majeure pour le président
en principe dans l'ensemble du rapport
on parle de blanchiment pour le
président et ses acolytes les plus
proches qui n'ont pas déjà été disons
leur épingle y parle enquête membres
parce qu en a qui sont tombés depuis les
deux dernières années
mais dans l'ensemble en principe celui
toi présumant que si et quand la
totalité du rapport est rendu public on
n'apprend pas certains détails qui
peuvent être plus compromettants
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve dans ce maquis
était préparée par foncièrement là une
personne monsieur bart et ses plus
proches de ceux ci au sommet du
département de la justice et ne se bat
donc quitter quelqu'un qui me suit
l'homme avait extrêmement confiant déjà
les démocrates joue la carte de la
méfiance celle que vous jouez aussi
charles philippe quant à la lecture du
rapport
monsieur bah avait dit qu'il rendrait
public la tout ce qu'il pouvait rendre
publique du rapport
les démocrates ont seules raisons de
vouloir exiger il aller très loin s'il
le faut pour avoir le contenu bah ils
ont certainement raison parce que c'est
la prérogative de la législature
américaine de faire comparaître tous les
acteurs d'un dossier comme celui-là est
d'exiger toute la documentation qu'ils
peuvent obtenir sauf secret de sécurité
nationale d'où le clavardage souvent
dans ce genre de rapport que vous allez
certainement retrouver dans ce qui sera
publié je m'attends à ce que alors je
m'attends à ce que les comités au
congrès veille en savoir beaucoup plus
obtenir la totalité du rapport s'ils le
peuvent effectivement de vouloir faire
comparaître la plupart de ses acteurs
dont le ministre de la justice dont le
procureur spécial robert mueller et bien
d'autres
est-ce que politiquement leur angle
d'attaqué sera le même que celui qu'il
voulait ou souhaitait ce matin en se
levant ça je rebondis sur ce que dit
cette fois christian j'en doute un peu
parce que à force de s'acharner sur
cette présumée collusion
effectivement il pourrait commencer à se
faire mal même les démocrates s'ils
rives encore le clou là dessus alors que
c'est assez bel et bien prouvé que ni
drogue ni sa famille surtout lors de
cette fameuse rencontre de juin 2016 où
la plupart d'entre nous avions des
doutes quand même sérieux sur ce qui
s'était passé entre cette rencontre avec
les russes il semble effectivement que
la famille d'une autre trempe
son fils hier et kouchner soit exonéré
de cet aspect là de la collusion
puis-je à dire juste un petit élément ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas eu plus
largement de la collusion entre des
éléments plus privés de la société russe
aura les appeler comme ça et des
intermédiaires de tranchant je pensais
en trop je parle sa forme à la fois sont
des gens qui ont été quand même en
contact avec des russes maintenant sur
la question au site de wikileaks est
défavorable elle sur la société mana
fort exactement
deuxième chose faut pas oublier je pense
raphaël aussi clairement sonné c'est il
ya toutes les finances autour de 200
roms qui seront encore scrutées par les
démocrates ils vont venir mais restons
sur le rapport est là parce que là pour
muller avait découvert en cours dans
quai avec le procureur spécial a
découvert en cours dans kent toutes
sortes de deux crimes commis par des
gens de l'entourage d'autres hommes
d'evans songe au congrès en cours
d'enquêté tout ça et certains disent
déjà que leurs formulaires vraiment
parler lorsqu'il a inculpé des gens et
que le vrai rapport muller s'est passé
quatre pages là c'est parce qu'on peut
avoir c'est celui qui va se déployer
devant les tribunaux américains soit new
york ou dans d'autres districts parce
qu'elle est proche de jambes même risque
d'être inculpé je vous dirai ça c'est
déjà fait oui en gros ça doit se faire
bien d'autres à venir
absolument et donc oui il ya quelque
chose de france poussins foncièrement
vrai laden pertinents prenez un type
comme pas mal fort on l'évoquait il ya
quelques instants
c'est quand même l'ex directeur de
campagne du président a laissé place aux
dirigeants en prison pour la prochaine
décennie peut-être un petit peu moins de
10 ans c'est quand même pas rien même si
à la base les raisons pour lesquelles on
l'inculpé on l'accusé on le condamne et
n'ont rien à voir avec la question de la
collusion dénoncé des fraudes bancaires
né par jour je comptais états unis mais
reste qu'à la base c'est fort à parier
qu'on ne leur est pas épinglé il ne
serait pas retrouvée pas en prison s'ils
répondent à une enquête majeure
alors vous n'étiez pas le mal à faire
c'est le seul procès que vraiment eu
lieu il ya été trouvé coupable
il ya été question beaucoup du pardon à
ce que monsieur jobs va faire bonne
position maintenant pour dire ben
écoutez garder l'eau n'ont rien à se
reprocher je peux maintenant pardonner à
celui qui a 69 ans un peu plus vient
d'être condamné sévèrement et qui
risquent de mourir en prison si je ne le
pardonne pas lui qui dépose je cerne
qu'ils donnent aux racks et programmes
et autres comme les coen et tous les
autres gates a comparé les rives ou
peut-être vous lisez l'avenir parce que
je mettais pas posé cette question elle
est excellente
effectivement de charme forte d'une
victoire politique voir ce qu'a fait
l'impasse peut-être pourraient être
tentés d'imposer déjà spectaculaire
comme cela et montrer à sa base
électorale que il se tient debout et
comme il n'a rien à se reprocher il
il va pas redonner des gens comme par
manas fort ça va dépendre j'imagine du
vin en politique ça va dépendre en quel
sens le vent tourner et ça tombe
beaucoup en faveur de dans leurs rangs
votre question n'est pas du tout du tout
exclu de se poser cette question là
vraiment c'est possible et en fait tu
peux me permettre
on a posé la question au président cette
semaine à la maison blanche
et sa réponse est non en fait c'était de
dire qu'il n'y avait même pas pensé sa
réhabilitation ton plus regardées pour
le bénéfice de nos téléspectateurs les
extraits qui sont les plus pertinents de
ce rapport de quatre pages du procureur
général de williams bat donc vois je
pense à fin juin 2010 match en direct on
s'attend à ce que le président descente
de son avion rapidement alors la
première le premier extrait l enquête
n'a pas prouvé que des membres de
l'équipe de campagne de dons en argent
pour conspirer ou encore donné leur
action avec le gouvernement russe a fait
interférer dans l'élection
je crois qu on le commande parce que
évidemment et on a mis en scène des
rencontres avec des avocats à la tour
trump en juin 2016 notamment proche du
gouvernement
certains ont dit que cette avocate
laouzas vocaux là c'était comme par le
gouvernement l'ambassadeur aussi russes
qui cela qui a parlé à flines et d'autre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire savelli
réaction avec le gouvernement russe
quand on a l'esprit toutes les
déclarations très familière et très
favorable ajoute yens de la part de je
pense anne marie c'est une question ça
pour les avocats parce que mon avis et
je suis pas dans le secret des dieux je
ne suis pas avocat
je pense que pour l'heure le critère
élabore était au par donnez moi un
bobard mais c'était de prouver hors de
tout doute raisonnable que des gens se
rencontrent avec la volonté de compléter
une action qui mène nuire aux chances de
hillary clinton et favoriser celle de
dans notre chambre
gardons là on le voit on peut pendant
que françois parle on voit monsieur
femmes qui arrivent il a passé le week
end très relax très calme géographie
devait savoir aux jeunes qui a eu des
communications peut-être pas désiré mai
entre ba et est généralement tenu fort
mais globalement de enfin et je pense
que si il avait été formellement mis
sous accusation par un peu mort dans une
accusation impardonnable je reviens
l'idée du smoking gun on entend par
exemple dans nos crânes dire à son fils
tu vas aller en bas au sixième état et
tu vas dire à notre représentant russe
que je veux obtenir quelque chose
je caricature pour démontrer à mon avis
le critère l'ajustement de collusion
c'est plus qu'on avait d'ailleurs
découvert avec nexen au téléphone quand
ils demandent où il dit à son aide de
camp beau brad de même je veux ceci où
je veux cela si on avait eu ceci je
pense que monsieur bas auraient dit les
nouvelles sont mauvaises monsieur le
président havrais lors obama se bat lui
dira dans notre homme je pense que vous
pouvez dormir tranquille et nouvelle me
semblent plutôt rassurantes
de la même façon que james commis avait
déjà dit non
comme lors de ce fameux dîner à la
maison blanche le président n'est pas
sous enquête actuellement en fonction de
ce que mike coughlan nous a révélé donc
dans notre jeu pouvait se dire rassurer
alors je pense qu'il devait être un peu
au courant oui pour les commémorations
il doit avoir un triomphe un peu modérer
parce qu'on s'est étonné tout le
week-end de son silence sur les réseaux
sociaux
ça contraste avec le week-end dernier où
ils en avaient fait une cinquantaine de
ces patients s'en tient il ne peut pas
se permettre d'avoir un triomphe
je sais que ça va être très intéressant
de voir comment ils jouent sont au
courant des prochains jours au coin des
prochaines semaines indépendamment de la
décision ultime qui a rendu par monsieur
bart à savoir est-ce qu'on diffuse le
rapport et si oui dans quelle mesure ça
va être intéressant de voir comment
d'autres chantent lajous il le fait que
monsieur tom demande qu'on garde ont dit
à 2,5 en garde
je démens crac le cas ils contestent le
caractère légal de l'enquète et de
contre attaquer il continue ses
partisans continuent de scander élevé
trenton l'accord hop je m'attends pas
dans leurs champs passage illusion
mais cela ne va pas changer d'un bon
ménage on a prouvé que j'ai pas fait de
la côte je me comporter comme un grand
président un nom là vous prenez des
rêves pour la réalité n'arrivera pas au
contraire je pense qu'il va être lors
d'un trait agressé prenant même
encouragé immobilisé motivé pour aller
en campagne
vous avez invité revoilà la pause pour
vous revenir après reparlé avec un
avocat républicain
monsieur quoi ce qui va décoiffer avec
son regard à lui pour vos contenus de
parler de la question de l'entrée avec
la justice parce que c'est là dessus
peut-être qu'ils allaient reculer encore
qui est encore vulnérable alors mesdames
messieurs rester avec nous la suite de
cette émission spéciale tout c'est après
la pause sur les conclusions du rapport
muller
on poursuit cette émission spéciale sur
les conclusions du rapport muller le
procureur général des états-unis rendu
public en fin d'après-midi une lettre de
quatre pages seulement concluant d'une
part qu'il y avait pas preuve de
collusion et de complot quant à
l'ingérence russe avec le gouvernement
russe de la part du président et de ses
collaborateurs à la campagne
présidentielle de 2016 et deuxième
conclusion concerne l'entravé à la
justice est ce que le président soit
pour faire un travail la justice
conclusion plus nuancé dans la mesure où
il n'y a pas de preuve hors de tout
doute que le président aurait pu faire
entrave à la justice notamment en
congédiant l'ancien directeur du fbi et
james cromitie par ailleurs viennent de
tweets et avec une photo / avec des
beaux-arts bras avec un petit soleil
derrière les arbres sur mes costumes
tant de questions comme si ce qui a été
rendu public aujourd'hui souffre
énormément de questions parce que sur
cette question d' entrave à la justice
évidemment c'est plus aussi pourquoi
parce que pas on n'a pas trouvé le
procureur spécial s'en remet au
procureur général pour décider s'il
devrait y avoir ou pas des accusations
en fait il dit je peux pas on peut pas
le pouvoir de tout doute raisonnable on
peut pas adhérer le président pour
autant on va en parler avec un avocat
républicain michael prauss qui procure
deux doigts l'université george mason en
virginie mais je croise merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation envoyée
lee point par point si vous les mains
d'avoir votre première lecture rapide de
ses conclusions
qu'est ce qu'elle vous inspire si tu
veux qu'ils aient prétend être exonérés
à 100% il n'est pas exonéré 100% mais je
dirais qu'il est exonéré abuse 70%
est ce suffisant parce que les gens et y
en a des milliers les gens qui détestait
monsieur tron ont tout misé sur la
populaire et pour eux je pense de toute
façon la question de la collusion de la
conspiration possible avec le
gouvernement russe
est ce que vous considérez que la
l'écriture de monsieur bah doit être
examinée de près en ce sens que chaque
mot compte parce qu'on sait que quand
même eu autour de monsieur trempette son
organisation beaucoup de contacts avec
les russes en périphérie peut-être que
c'était pour les affaires personnelles
d'octobre
peut-être pas pour les gérants il ya
quand même la faire de wikileaks qui est
importante
est ce que est ce que c'est parce qu'on
n'a pas publié puis vous êtes juriste
l'homme le président franck avec le
gouvernement russe est à dire poutine ce
biais deux questions est-ce que des
gouvernements étrangers ou des personnes
privées étrangères ont tenté de
s'ingérer dans la campagne américaine
certainement oui ça se passe tout le
temps ça se passait toutes les élections
d'ailleurs les états unis singer
constamment dans les élections de pays
étrangers
vos auditeurs se rappellent peut être
monsieur obama qui a tenté au
gouvernement d' influencer les élections
israéliennes pour obtenir la défaite de
monsieur netanyahou toxa c'est pas la
question la question était s'il y'avait
participation active de la part de la
campagne trump avec 7
ces projets étrangers donc les étrangers
eux c'est une chose comme c'est une
autre chose et je pense que monsieur
bart il n'aurait pas émis ces quatre
pages 6 et 4 pages de bep vente ul m'en
être contredite à le rapport aux six
mosquées dieu sait que le rapport entier
se rendre échappée du sur annuler
sinon publié des extraits importants
seront révélés à la presse par d'autres
personnes selon vous est ce que monsieur
baril devrait carrément le rendre public
au nom de la transparence
la loi est assez clair là dessus
d'une part le rapport de müller est
confidentielle selon la loi c'est le mot
clé dans la loi de confidentiel au
procureur général donc monsieur muller
lui même ne peut pas le révéler quant à
monsieur bart il ya deux choses qui ne
peut révéler des secrets relevé à la
sécurité nationale d'une part et le
résultat des témoignages devant le grand
jury d'autre part c'est le jaune ne
peuvent absolument pas être révélé ce
sera une violation sacré de la loi donc
qui ne peut révéler tout le rapport à ça
c'est sûr qu'est-ce qui peut révéler
évident léger précieux il a dit qu'il va
révéler tout ce qui peut d'accord une
autre conclusion
c'est là aussi que très intéressant
parce qu'elle concerne le comportement
du président trump sur la question de l'
entrave à la justice depuis le
congédiement de james commis jusqu'à en
passant par toutes ces déclarations
intimidante c'est c6 tweed ses
déclarations sur la chasse aux sorcières
sur ces interrogations auprès certaines
personnes ou est ce qui inquiète ses
enquêtes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ça monsieur
vilain monsieur mila excusez-moi j'ai
complété monsieur muller s'en remet à
monsieur barry sais pas monsieur muller
lui-même
et ça ça soulève des questions oui
monsieur bart est avocat et c'est
l'avocat en chef des états unis et les
avocats américains on touche le devoir
déontologique
les avocats de la kora pas chez vous les
avocats de la couronne les ceux qui
poursuivent les les causes pénales ont
le devoir éthique de ne jamais
poursuivre quelqu'un en moins d'être sûr
à leur avis qu'ils ont des preuves
au-delà de tout doute raisonnable
et il est vrai que monsieur tron c'est
son pire ennemi
il rit des choses est il dit il est dit
des choses vraiment douteuses médias
toujours une explication innocents et
coupables et monsieur molaires je pense
c'est une âme pressage des gars à mon
avis le plus grand gagnant de tout ceci
c'est robert mueller ah oui en des
moqueries
mais pour l'heure a reconnu que la cause
était la probabilité faible
oui allez on va parler le bénéfice de
noter les voix monsieur muller à l'écran
au moment où vous nous parler on va
mettre le l'ex trader de la lettre de
monsieur ben le procureur général qui
cite le rapport muller une phrase
seulement où on dit le conseiller
spécial précise le procureur spécial
précise que bien que ce rapport ne
conclut pas que le président fait
entrave à la justice
il ne l'exonère pas pour autant alors
c'est ça alors certains vont y voir là
une porte ouverte à mener d'autres
d'autres enquêtes de la part du congrès
peut-être non il y avait toujours une
échappatoire lorsqu'il amis
à pied monsieur corps mais il avait il
et il était en possession du rapport
darrois grozny thank you procureur
général qui justifiait la musique le
mises à pied lorsqu'il a miroiter devant
certaines personnes la possibilité d'un
pardon il y avait toujours la
possibilité il y avait l'interprétation
innocenté une interprétation coupable il
ne sent bon et je suis président je vous
aime vous êtes un type gentil vous êtes
bon père de famille je vais avoir de la
pitié pour vous et coupable écoutez
fermer la gueule ne témoigne est pas et
dieu ciel je veux vous pardonner est ce
qu'on peut trouver l'eau l'autre non et
c'est ça le problème pour ne produit pas
lorsqu'il ya un doute raisonnable
en même temps on a posé la question du
pardon quant à mana fort est ce que vous
croyez que maintenant monsieur trompe à
la voie libre pour pardonner son grand
ami le seul qui ne l'a pas oui j'ai
entendu savoir la pause j'ai souri je
suis encore mon opinion monsieur le chat
n'est pas bonne mais même même mémo
l'opinion de monsieur thiam sera
énormément pire cilicie pardonne
monsieur nana pas s'il parle de monsieur
le rapport il va transformer une
victoire en défaite totale parce que mes
rapports et détesté les faits qui ont
été révélés pendant son procès ont
démontré un type qui ceux qui méprisent
la loi qui a fait des dizaines peut être
des centaines de millions de dollars qui
était vraiment un mercenaire avant même
de travailler pour trump c'était ça ne
sert à rien d'avoir des 3,3 pendant ce
type là ce soir qu'il est son pire
ennemi alors je suis en terminant avec
vous mais je joins kamano nous prenons
pas nos invités sur le plateau à notre
conversation une constation spécifique
pour vous parce que comme juriste
quand on regarde il ya eu un travail de
soupçons d'entravé à la justice on ne
peut pas le prouver quand même
mais le simple fait que müller et pu
terminer son rapport que même ces
nominations de
oui tout comme procureur général
intérimaire ou même moule et amber tous
des gens qui étaient critiques qui ne
croyait pas à la nécessité de cette
enquête là est ce que c'est une victoire
de l'état de droit de la démocratie
quand même aux états unis
en cinq ans le disent ils oui à mon avis
absolument comme je vous ai dit c'est
une victoire pour robert müller il a
résisté aux critiques acerbes aux
critiques vulgaire de monsieur thual
répétées et il a produit un rapport
sobre et des produits rapporte
conformité avec son mandat et avec la
loi et on devrait être fier de lui je
pense qu'il en sort vraiment tandis que
les perdants ce sont ces dégâts que
c'est à la fois trump qui a toujours
démontré du mépris pour monsieur molac
et aussi certains démocrates qui ont qui
ont exprimé avec certitude
l'idée qui avait collusion avec trapèze
sans aucune preuve et je pense que les
deux vraiment perdre la face
c'est moller qui en sort victorieux
wesh acharnée pour venir peut-être
quelque chose je répèterai effectivement
ce que monsieur kraus bien de dire en
effet il ya eu tellement de scepticisme
de doute de confiance minet dans le
système politique américain dans le lait
contrepoids constitutionnel contrepoids
politique aussi qu'on peut voir non
effectivement le fait que j'ai pu
terminer son rapport aurait pu le
déposer et arrivent à des conclusions
qui honnêtement je pense surprennent
tout le monde ce soir je dis oui je m'y
attendais des gens qui disent tout ça
pour ça
ces 25 milliards ces deux autres princes
appelé non mais c'est bien la preuve que
même le président le plus intempestifs
qu'on ait vu de tous les présidents de
l'ère moderne n'a pas été capable et n'a
pas seulement mis fin au travail et qui
était nécessaire pas seulement pour
savoir si dans notre homme lui même
à l'instar de richard nixon avait
commandé ordonné cette collusion mais
qui d'autre est impliquée je rebondis
sur deux ou trois choses quand même
encore important qu'il faut dire ce soir
ce n'est pas parce que le président est
exonéré si cela s'avère selon le rapport
qui sera remis que pour voter
tous ces aides de quinte ou ses
conseillers tous les gens qui ont
travaillé avec lui le sont au contraire
vous avez évoqué le cas de prendre ma
foi ça c'est déjà quelque chose qu'il
faut retenir c'est très très important
et une question pour vous monsieur cross
le fait que robert müller n'est pas pu
interroger directement le président
entre hommes
est-ce que ça enlève delà de la
pertinence parce que sans armes sur une
saveur à son rapport parce qu'on sait
que le président a répondu simplement un
questionnaire écrit oui c'est une
tradition américaine assez fort c'est la
séparation des pouvoirs constitutionnels
tous les présidents qu'ils soient
démocrates ou républicains et
indépendants résistera à de telles
demandes d'autres pu je pense que entre
adéquat comme ça déjà ça bien être dit
les traditions légal et traditions
juridiques viennent tout d'être
confirmée pas ce que monsieur muller 10
et même la façon dont il a mené son
entreprise il a il n'a jamais répondu
aux insultes personnelles
lancé par monsieur trump et à ceux qui
suivent la carrière de monsieur muller
suivent la carrière d'un homme
absolument
au delà de toute substance est un type
vraiment quittait honneur au lula est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à faire l'aspect
ratio l'air prenne la parole à un moment
donné parce que pour certains son écoute
monsieur kraus on le prend au mot
muller et devient une sorte de héros de
la démocratie
dépendent encore une fois gardons une
petite gêne l'intégralité exactement
l'intégralité du rapport on ne le code
n'est pas ne la connaît pas plus tôt
donc attendons mais heureusement que oui
la réponse est oui monsieur kraft canada
mme pelosi donc la leader des démocrates
est monsieur schmitt 10 la lettre du
procureur général cette petite lettre de
quatre pages soulève plus de questions
qu'elle n'apporte de réponses qu'est ce
que vous dites vous je dis qu'ils sont
en train de tenter de sauver la face
ils ont trop mis sur le rapport aux
enquêtes muller
monsieur tron a commis tellement de
délire tellement défaut de caractère
tellement de problèmes de personnalité
mais ils ont tout misé sur le soi-disant
la soi disant solution avec les
soviétiques où les russes et maintenant
il tente de sauver la face en disant
qu'à écouter ya plus là et ibo d'espérer
que ça va mourir lentement au lieu
d'être de mourir subitement de jour à
l'autre le public comme ceux déjà été
dit est tenu de tout ça et j'ai
l'impression qu'ils vont ils vont lancer
sa tombe et à l'obscurité mais ça leur
voix jusqu'à quand même des questions
qui viennent qui vous viennent à
l'esprit à la suite du dépôt
ces quatre lettres de cette lettre de
quatre pages me pose des questions
écoutez moi je serais intéressé à savoir
si jamais on met la main sur quelques
uns des accusés russie d'une part
d'autre part celui qui a un contre deux
membres de tank est parce que la
campagne électeurs de madame clinton a
embauché là une société exel fusion gps
cette société a fait appel à un espion
britannique christopher stills important
étrangers hostiles qui a produit le
dossier qu'à utiliser les failles pour
justifier la surveillance donc il est
maintenant possible ce serait à mon avis
une mauvaise décision
la part des républicains il est possible
que les républicains disent écoutez se
met à genoux qui prétendant que c'est
vous qui avez connu qui nous écoutent
avec l'étranger oui enfin parce qu'au
fond n'est jamais la ligne des
républicains prochaine monsieur kraus 10
et câline les républicains le début des
partisans de monsieur pierre ça va dans
le sens de ce que madame madame acabit
ça nous a déclaré c'est qu'ils ont été
aujourd'hui sont vengés les républicains
parce qu'ils ont toujours vu dans cette
histoire là un complot des démocrates
avec ce que monsieur cross se dit le
fameux d'aussi de dossiers comme les
appelle le cuistot refuse-t-il réateur
défense faut retenir notre souffle au
pas non plus être trouvé ton affaire on
ne dispose encore une fois raphaël le
dire une reprise monsieur kraus
d'inciter 4 pas au travail ce qu'on en
attendait d'avoir beaucoup plus qu'on
n'a pas ouais je pense pas que les
comités au congrès vont arrêter de faire
leur travail doit par exemple comité du
renseignement comité judiciaire comité
de supervision du gouvernement et vont
continuer de demander à tous les gens
qui entourent dans l'eau mais vous étiez
vous à dentelles dossiers tels dossiers
tels dossiers
je l'aï rapidement parce que monsieur
david à vendre ce point théorie c'est un
fait voilà démocrates l'ont dit
publiquement une ode au courant du
week-end non dits prêts parce que
monsieur maurer a découvert ou révèle
dans ce fameux rapport là nous on va
continuer à enquêter sur la question en
russe est beaucoup plus largement que ça
gardons en tête que les démocrates on le
sait sont majoritaires à la chambre des
représentants depuis les deux derniers
mois et jusqu'à la fin tout au moins du
premier mandat du président ils vont
avoir le voir dans quête sur cette
question là il sera peu près n'importe
quelle question qu'il juge pertinent
bien mais peut-être que les démocrates
voient un clip de parler d'autre chose
que ce aussi pour faire valoir les idées
qu'ils défendent en vue de l'élection
présidentielle ça va être aussi leur
diffusion
n'est ce pas monsieur croix là dessus je
vous remercier d'avoir pris quelques
minutes de votre dimanche soir pour nous
parler encore une fois c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous parler
m croire à la prochaine loi n'est pas
fini alors je retourne à washington que
sans la treille la commune présent la
question de la gestion de la chambre des
représentants
jordan lui a réagi finalement oui john a
relooké qui préside la commission
judiciaire congrès et qui enquête sur
différentes facettes d affaires de 2
dans l'autre chambre et on a bien raison
de dire qu'effectivement le congrès et
particulièrement les démocrates n'ont
n'arrêteront pas demain matin d'enquêté
on enquête sur ces affaires on enquête
sur la tour 1 moscou on enquête sur les
clauses des émoluments il ya des
poursuites
alors monsieur n'a d'yeux qui en trois
points a très bien résumé je pense que
plusieurs démocrates pensent ce soir que
ce n'est pas une exonération totale de
monsieur choï et qui reste encore là
beaucoup beaucoup de travail à faire
pour aller au fond des choses je laisse
entendre monsieur n'à re le conseil
spécial a passé 22 mois à chercher des
éléments de preuve d' obstruction et
d'autres inconduite le hockey en général
baraki actionner pour son rôle avec un
emmerdeur qui suggère qu'elles n'étaient
pas valables comme enquête est que le
président que c'était impossible pour le
président de commettre l'obstruction de
justice parce qu'il est
la tête de l'exécutif il a pris une
décision sur ces données probantes dans
48 heures alors ses conclusions mais n'a
d'autres questions ne répond pas à nos
questions et le fait que mahler à
trouver des données probantes qui
n'exonère pas selon lui le président
c'est inacceptable que le président
essaye de tourner ça en sa faveur comme
si sa conduite était acceptable de
quelque façon que ce soit deuxièmement
étant donné ces questions il est
important que le procureur général
publie le play rapport et tous les
toutes les données probantes le rapport
non filtrés ainsi que tout les éléments
de preuve tous les clés de l'éprouvante
doivent être rendus disponibles au
congrès américain au peuple américain et
on doit mettre l'information disponible
le plus possible pour le dispute pour le
public alors je veux cette transparence
nous allons demander au procureur
général donner son témoignage
nous avons deux mois demandé le rapport
plein et non filtré les le peuple
américain a droit à pleine transparence
troisièmement le procureur général
ces commentaires font en sorte que le
congrès doit travailler à trouver la
vérité et la transparence pour le peuple
américain
le président n'a pas été exonéré par le
conseil spécial mais le procureur
général a décidé de ne pas continuer de
partir ne pas partager sa vie alors quel
sens le congrès va faire son travail
d'enquêté ce que monsieur ne nous dit
mais c'est important de rappeler aussi
que le rapport l'enquète müller en
révéler ce que vous avez évolué et est
ce que vous avez évoqué la présentation
de monsieur nadler des éléments qui
sont à l'origine d'autres enquêtes pour
ne pas dire d'autres inculpations et
tout ça va se passer à new york
principalement oui à new york dans le
service district il y aura là plusieurs
enquêtes qui ont d'ailleurs été référées
par roberte mort le à ses procureurs et
ils sont encore en train de travailler
on verra bien les conclusions de tout ça
mais vous savez anne-marie je pense
qu'il est important de retenir la sécu
ce qui va rester
est ce qu'on appelle en anglais de big
picture puisque les américains entendent
ce soir je pense que c'est ça qui va
rester parce que de ne par votre invité
avait raison de dire que monsieur bart
peu importe ce qu'il y a eu ce qu'on
découvre éventuellement comme détails
comme substance dans les problèmes en
les centaines de pages de rapports du
rapport moral ce que les gens vont
retenir c'est le fait que sur ces deux
thèmes de la halle entrave à la justice
et la collusion avec les russes monsieur
de chambre a été blanchi monsieur ben
n'aurait jamais pris le risque de
raconter des mensonges ou oui c'est sa
vision des choses effectivement mais si
comme procureur général on découvrait
qu'il avait menti ou qu'il avait juste
ortio n'est la réalité
je pense que
il perdrait beaucoup de crédibilité et
monsieur bart en a beaucoup encore
auprès du public américain et auprès des
gens au congrès donc ce serait
intéressant oui de voir de quelle
manière les démocrates vont enquêter
mais je pense ce qui va rester c'est ce
qu'on entend ce soir et c'est une grande
victoire dans l'autre chambre et une
jupe une gifle solide aux démocrates
en effet merci beaucoup christian on va
vous entendre vous voir dans les
prochains téléjournaux au cours des
prochaines heures et prochains jours
parce que vous allez voir beaucoup de
travail encore cette semaine à couvrir
le dénouement de cette histoire donc du
rapport müller dont les complots des
rendus publics par la procureure
générale cet après-midi merci christian
bonne on s'en va une brève pause
mesdames messieurs venez avec nous après
la pause john parisella se joint à la
conversation avec charles david et
rappelle jacob
iran 1979 une révolution d'une ampleur
considérable marque un tournant décisif
dans l'histoire du pays
[Applaudissements]
le peuple montre aux états unis et au
reste de la planète qu'il rejette en
bloc l'intervention occidentale
aujourd'hui ce pays placé sous
l'étendard de l'islam est l'un des plus
influents du moyen-orient on souligner
le 40e anniversaire de la révolution
iranienne
suivez notre programmation spéciale aux
grands reportages du 1er au 5 avril 20
heures ici r10
[Musique]
pas certain
et si vous aviez un peu dead aid 2019
avec toute la confiance qu apporte la
technologie comporte 3 60
la technologie d'assistance au
conducteur la plus avancée de la
catégorie
le nouveau hedge 2019 s'est poursuit des
études universitaires était engagée dans
son milieu
le programme hausse avenir universitaire
en or les jeunes qui enrichissent notre
société fait rayonner son audace et son
leadership et soumettons initiatives
pour ces venir entre plus de 114
millions $ en bourses dans différentes
catégories
un comme toi au bureau de la vie
étudiante de l'université où à force à
venir point qc.ca la date limite
d'inscription est le 31 mars
[Musique]
reconnaître et promouvoir l'engagement
étudiant je vous donnais un truc pour
payer votre hôtel moins cher c'est
facile allez surtout vagues ont trouvé
rapidement l'eau thème qui vous convient
comparer les différents prix pour le
même hôtel 5 efficace un hôtel rivaldo
fixe autour le premier mot auquel on
devrait penser après un accident sous
peu
sherbrooke est beau de produits québec
issime ou chaudes starmania
nikitotek centre-ville de sherbrooke
[Musique]
découvrir les saveurs du roadster
poulain tient poulet périphérie de
nouveau cette superbe full vivre vous
aimez les surprises
[Musique]
ouais
de grandes surprises
de grosses surprises
l'ex énorme surprise
ça fait 20 ans que kiabi sopra et se
fait juste commencé et voici une autre
belle surprise
l'ajac juillet de nommer la qui
atteignait voiture canadienne de l'année
[Musique]
le président trois passants tout de
bonnes raisons de crier victoire
aujourd'hui avec la publication de la
lettre du procureur général bolger
référant aux conclusions du rapport
muller de grandes conclusions dont l'une
les exclut complètement la collusion
notamment en matière en ce qui a trait à
la gérance russe
mais pour ce qui est de l'entrée à la
justice on le dit en début d'émission et
au cours de l'émission c'est beaucoup
plus nuancé cela dit le président turc
contre attaque déjà se tourner contre
les démocrates qu'il tient responsable
de site de cette enquête est de ces deux
ans dans le fond de deux ans d'enquêté
qui ont perturbé la vie politique
américaine
j'apprends avec john parisella
professeur invité au sérieux
john vous êtes au téléphone ce soir
merci d'avoir plus de temps à nous
parler écoutez je sais pas si on peut
imaginer que si 30 prix victoire c'est
que tellement de gens qui étaient
tellement convaincus qu'ils avaient les
collusions puis il y avait tellement
convaincu que la formule heures à
l'envoyer je prends pas en prison où
allait le faire destituer certainement
beaucoup de gens déçus par ce qu'ils ont
mangé le démocrate nom est john et j'ai
fait ce que les démocrates vont être
déçus puis peut-être un certain nombre
d'indépendants comme électeurs vont être
déçus des républicains il ya une
certaine classe politique la politique
aux techniques qui t'a le passé début du
quinquis entre des fans de monsieur
trump s'est claqué à un ennemi d'un
élections les démocrates qui le
publicain qui veulent obtenir le
contrôle du sénat
peut-être même avant de faire des gains
à la chambre de la cnsa farc à la maison
blanche ils sont pour mesurer
aujourd'hui ce que faut voir l'elisir
des républiques et des derniers temps de
s'équiper avoir de rapport aux gens qui
voulaient la voir
ils ont dévoilé à fatalité suppose
cependant voir le même discours dans les
clochers jour et monsieur fabre et il
est rapide il a déjà indiqué qu' elle
est totalement exonérée même si c'est
presqu'à en ce qui concerne entrave à la
justice pis et encore beaucoup d'autres
enquêtes dans d'autres domaines il n'y a
pas de bruit ce que monsieur somme se
dégage régalien et bangoura les juges
soir où il va seulement beaucoup de
tweets
ouais c'est son grand
sa grande force flamme de récupérer par
toujours les mêmes lignes on l'attendait
tout le temps dire non quand le jeune
live à dire c'est la victoire qui l'a
complètement absous de tous les
reproches qui lui avait été faite tout
les motifs dans quatre maintenant ça
veut dire quoi pour les démocrates le
défi des démocrates maintenant pour moi
peut-être la plus la personne
l'affichage des démocrates et derniers
temps c'est vrai mais nancy peut lui
aussi qui a 46 ans que l'on évoqué les
possibilités de pikmin c'est apprendre
que sa priorité qui envoyait à voyez
vraiment la possibilité de gagner un
vote à la chambre des représentants l'a
pas gagné un procès au sénat et que ça
pourra juste diviser le pays donc on est
à un an et demi mon époque on n'est pas
tout à fait dans une situation que
monsieur nexus est un excellent est au
début d'un deuxième terme dont on est
passé la demi d'un premier thème les
démocrates ont environ une dizaine de 15
500 en marche
si la formule de leur victoire au monde
l'an passé c'était de répondre aux
besoins de la population et on prend
vraiment fait la campagne ce monsieur tu
te trompes au moins d'allant je passais
[ __ ] et tant que c'est un référendum
ce monsieur ce monsieur forme comme tel
donc je pense que j'ai fourni c'est de
se concentrer sur la population oui
devant des enquêtes ça va continuer la
chambre des représentants ça donne de
suite les tops new york pour continuer
il y en a d'autres dans le district
alors le conduit beaucoup des attaques
ce monsieur femmes sont beaucoup sur sa
personne c'est son organisation sa
fondation
toute la question de stormy des agneaux
qui décide d'acheter son silence tout
sauf volé c'est quand même dans dans le
décor meyer est ce que faut que les
démocrates pensent aussi à gagner une
élection pas comme monsieur tram mais
pour leur vision et leur le rêve n'est
l'avenir des états unis qui jugent des
voix nettement la division qu'on sera de
plus en plus dans les discours de
certains des candidats ou contacter ma
patate pour le high tech est mais on est
encore très tôt pour les démocrates mais
c'est il donne au passage seulement sur
le référendum avec dans l'autre sens
avec un économie qui roulent très dit au
moment constat donc je pense cela le
conseil sujet
un conseiller démocrate parce que
l'oubli mais toute l'histoire de sauver
des alliances la question du monument
c'est rien à voir avec l'an 4000 rc les
autres enquêtes effectuées et ferrer
périphériques qui pourrait donner
ouverture à des inculpations des
inculpations même pour un président trop
interrompre une prescription sont si on
demande ses revenus qu'on se rend compte
qu'il ya des faux déclarations à des
banques à la deutsche bank par exemple
ce qui est ce qui est sujette à enquête
en ce moment ça peut lui rendre la vie
plus difficile banques et müller quand
je ne puis oublier que quand même la
seule parmi les même si aujourd'hui
monsieur comme que les victoires
il est quand même au delà de 180 papa
passe à 99 accusations criminelles qui
ont été faites durant 7 7 1 4
sept personnes ont été mises en
accusation sept coupable et cinq qui ont
su défense dont ne fait pas de ce
travail dans de beaux chats point qu'il
faut dont on parle beaucoup de la
possibilité d'un pardon ne faisait qu'un
actions qui vont avoir des accusations
au niveau des lecteurs d'aller de new
york et qui se sait accusations là ne
sont pas sujets impartialement faut
qu'ils soient à sa passion merci
beaucoup de jeunes parisiens on se
retrouve aucun américain alors
conclusion très dur ça fait un bout
d'abord raphaël ce que vous retenez ce
qu'on veut faire mettant de bière deux
points sur lesquels dont un homme sort
renforcée suite
la journée d'aujourd'hui la première
c'est que la requête est terminée ça va
de rien je sais que ça a l'air non 22
mois l' enquête qui va commencer avec
sous la présidence clinton sous le
scandale sur le scandale white wolf
avait duré plus de cinq ans ça avait
couvert la majorité des 2 mandat de bill
clinton à la maison blanche
dans ce cas-ci même ça pu sembler
périlleux a été élu avec un premier
mandat s'était construit avec ont semé
pendant le deuxième mandat autrement dit
ça te paraît comme une éternité pour la
maison blanche actuelle dans notre
chambre mais au final savoir quand même
duré moins 2 1 et 2 c'est fini c'est bon
pour lui politiquement ça c'est une
chose
la deuxième c'est que ça lui permet
également de frapper un grand coup sur
un de ses sites préférés les médias
parce que pendant deux ans dans notre
champ part accusé les médias de propager
les forces nouvelles est monté en
épingle cette histoire de collusion là
comment pensez vous qu'il va réagir
suite ou résumés de monsieur bart
aujourd'hui c'est sûr et certain il
reste bel et bien en 10 secondes chacune
de conclusion aussi la première sur le
domaine de la décision n'a jamais été
aussi loin d'une telle perspective que
ce soir donc ceux qui voulaient celle
qui voulait d sion 2 dans le temps que
je pense ça n'arrivera pas et deuxième
conclusion dans le tram sera fort
probablement donc candidat aux
présidentielles de 2020 renforcer les
conclusions soumis aujourd'hui alors
j'en fais david graf et jacob c'est un
plaisir de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau en ce beau dimanche soir merci à
suivre au cours des prochains jours
madame messieurs merci d'avoir suivi
cette émission spéciale sur les
conclusions du rapport muller comme sont
rendus publics cet après midi
bonne fin de soirée à notre antenne bien
sûr les téléjournaux vont couvrir cette
soir au revoir